hi it's Matthew Martin from details and
we just finished the jury's van noten
show here in Paris I really liked how
the whole show was a plan opposite it
was night closed mixed with date clothes
it was men fabrics mixed with women's
fabrics there were these very beautiful
sparkly sweaters it almost looked like
women's sweaters but I thought they went
great with these great like really
masculine leather studded trousers
there's a lot of embellishment there's a
lot of embroidery there was a lot of big
paisley print also mixed with really
simple low V crewneck sweaters that were
in mohair that was kind of baggy the
coats were gorgeous there was some
really beautiful shorter jackets that
had these great sort of shearling
collars there was also these beautiful
long top coats it's the mix that makes
it modern and this was really obvious in
this collection i think you know it's
all about mixing up what you think goes
together and pairing it with items that
you might not normally pair with like
for example i love that there was these
pajama ETOPS that they had with more you
know classic trousers or mixing these
like sort of very traditional english
fabrics in a new and cooler way he's a
master at reinterpreting like what you
normally think of in terms of menswear
and here i think that was no different
with the fact that there was all these
feminine delicate items but there were
all paired together in a super masculine
way